tink hey dig dig welcome back to this
Julian and Jenna Potter that [ __ ] me up
okay generally about you already booth
we need we're gonna prank you guys and
just counting alphabetical order
casually refer to podcaster the Julian
agent at this week and it's a possibly
also just like hold hands all time
addresses PPP I guess it didn't work
welcome back everyone with gingerly
podcast CEO yielding us for another week
another one another one but we got we're
doing some dumb [ __ ] as you can see
we're sitting here with our left up
today you're sitting here with our
laptops today because we have written a
whole lot of [ __ ] we had the idea to do
a choose-your-own-adventure
podcast where we each write an adventure
with multiple choices and sub choices
and more sub choices that allows the
other person to choose their own
adventure and find out what awaits after
each decision mm-hmm so I mean sweet
well one but like that it's a lot of
writing yes a lot of the time we
initially plan on doing three stories
each to read to each other but then we
started writing really low because we
that's right sort of like a whole sub
story for each choice and so I wrote one
in general one yeah and we can go
through the different choices we
definitely will go through the different
choices even if you didn't take them
because we ain't wasting this writing
Julian by the way I like your glasses
oh thank you Julian got glasses for the
first time in his life boy I feel like I
have to apologize why I have said on the
podcast before hundred percent that I
have gray vision and vision so I'm
eating my words welcome to the club
Julie thank you um it only gets away
from red and then things get really but
you cannot see yeah it's weird because I
genuinely found my vision was just like
there wasn't better vision and then I
tried on glasses and I was like wait a
minute I can see better and I was like a
foreign concept to me so I do want to
say I'm sorry we forgive you I actually
picked out frames that are pretty much
identical to dwight's frames on the
office and paid out which I didn't even
realize just any def def target in that
picture and I was like wait they are
exactly the same friend I prayed up
thank you dear I appreciate it so who's
going first uh I would say ladies first
but I'm afraid to follow your epic story
with my probably not as epic story let's
see your face okay so I get to play
right here's a quaver I haven't read
anything that you know you get to play
first
alright I'm ready I'm excited are you
done writing it's exciting
alright okay here we go
choose your own adventure Scientology
has started to bother youtubers and
hopes of them joining the cult and
spreading their message oh my god that's
too real they are persistent and
relentless in going to the lengths I
would involve your life becoming data a
Scientologist denying would involve a
life of fear and that they are going to
retaliate against you non-stop do you a
give in to the pressure and join the
cult at least you'll get to meet John
sorry at least you'll get to meet John
Travolta and Tom Cruise is John Travolta
son yeah your YouTube channel becomes a
series of creepy mind-control videos but
at least you're getting millions of
views and making a [ __ ] ton of money on
the downside you're not entering an
arranged marriage and Scientology
controls every move in your life the
arranged marriage happens to be with
Greg Kinnear but he still thinks he's
shooting the movie stuck on you so your
entire relationship is him basically
living the plot of stuck on you every
single day that's choice one oh my god
choice to tell them to get [ __ ] become
a clown go to clown school
and learn how to make balloon bicycles
and do magic at kids parties but you
also learn the incredible secretive side
of being a clown you're now in
possession of top-secret confidential
information that could dissolve all the
world's governments as we know it you
begin to be initiated in a clown group
that is planning a massive conspiracy to
overthrow the planet
or tie you become a Scientologist and
start spreading your message but you are
purely doing it to further your true
career as an investigative journalist
you're undercover and finding out every
single dirty little secret that they're
hiding after years and years you find
out that you have enough info and secret
footage to release your documentary
Scientology small OG and after it's
released you disappear into Disneyland
every day for the rest of your life
you found a Mickey costume that you can
hide it I'm choosing the second one
using the second one I'm choosing the
second one but we can still hear your
other adventures but for now but for now
with fall I don't becoming a clown so
you've become a clown you were initiated
into a secret of clown group that's
planning a yes you worldwide overthrow
yes all right
so now that you're in the clown group a
do you go along with the clown
initiative even though all your friends
make fun of your being a clown you get
bullied on Twitter every day you wish
day in and day out and you can one day
live in a world where only clowns and
all only clowns existed in all non
clowns would be expelled from earth
every time a non clown was being
expelled they would be thrown through
the atmosphere and the sound of a
squeaky clown nose played every single
time they exited the atmosphere on last
week that's a guy that's choice a choice
B the whole time you're faking being a
clown because you get to you get to eat
free cupcakes and muffins each morning
and now they have been sorry and you've
now been given a genetic power that only
the clown community has access to this
power is something you can't quite
figure out that you've identified
certain characteristics up
they include whenever you honk at
someone your car instead of the clown
honking noise it blasts the social
security number of whoever you're
honking of the same volume and over a
normal car horn or play in addition you
can no longer tell time
you don't understand the day as you used
to see you're constantly losing sleep
and showing up late to places and lastly
every time someone squeezes your clown
nose you involuntarily shout out the
slogan for either subway Allstate or ha
ha hi Jersey boy one more choice what
there's why did you write three choices
because the next one only has one
outcome okay okay I did a little bit on
you I think okay the third choice is you
hear yourself way too deep into the
clown gang culture and we find every
night to be a terrifying existence not
knowing when the next clown side will
run up on you as a squirt gun and
potentially in your clown life your
clown dog poops a lot in this scenario
nobody knows why except him
he's hiding something from you you
wonder in wonder what it could be but
he's a dog he just says bark every time
you ask him what you know I'm choosing
be choosing be good at all right so you
choosing or you've chosen the year of a
clown superpower and you're not sure
exactly what it is but yeah peace and I
like that the the horn honks people
Social Security numbers okay so this is
your reality now there's no more choices
so this is how it ends up the
characteristics were actually signed
that you hadn't fully taken to the clown
gene altering process and you're still
part human this worked in your favor
though because there was a clown
pocalypse where all the clown's turn
into pitas eating penis eating monsters
blog julienne they would run around
ravaging penis forever they should find
it human goat famous people all kinds of
penis you luckily have no taste for dick
though you're slowly distancing yourself
from the clown affiliations you want
Todd you end up with a disturbed past
life and a new life stuck worrying about
your penis not being eaten as a daily
basis until your dying day found hell
thank you Julien veggie resistance
that's better than being in Scientology
though tbh fry give eh half clown
guarding a teen but I don't have a bean
what happens to girl clowns clown it's
um you still eat penis but you also
gotta make an opinion okay okay do you
want to hear the other outcomes yeah
okay so if you would all right so let's
just play it again the play again okay
so the Scientology thing do you want to
join in this time let's join in give in
to the pressure okay sit into the pivot
into the pressure of the cult and used
to be Tom Cruise John Travolta and your
man
- Greg Kinnear tight so moving forward
your happily divorced with Greg Kinnear
I guess you won't stop reliving stuck
not you yes you guys are for us very
early on you fought hard to maintain the
ability to make youtube videos except
now you have to send every single video
you create to Diamond Donson ahead of
content partnerships for the Church of
Scientology you instead of ask people to
subscribe to your channel have to tell
them to subscribe and join to the search
of Church of Scientology if you try to
skip an upload or upload without getting
approval on a video there at your house
within an hour with paintball guns
shooting Ferrero Rocher at you putting
responses yeah candy yeah instead of
paintball that's what comes all night
chocolate candy forever sure for sure
for sure they're delicious but they hurt
you do you a continue to upload as they
have said and suffer no pushback be quit
uploading and try to delete your channel
see skip an upload so you can collect
the most Pro returns you can possibly
get that way okay you go on a 40-day
binge of eating nothing but Ferrero
Rocher I get so sick of eating a bunch
of stuff then you have to get inventive
and create new recipes just using the
ingredients inside of Afrojack you
invented the forever chair dog which is
basically just for a chair and I melted
for a richer on top but for some reason
it becomes a worldwide phenomenon you
make billions of dollars off the Ferraro
dog Empire you then use your winnings to
convert the Church of Scientology into a
fully functioning Willy Wonka Chocolate
Factory that exclusively produces
forever chip that's do like yes such a
[ __ ] to life do you wanna know what
would happen if you were to quit
uploading and delete your channel yeah
if you try to quit uploading delete your
channel your channel was linked to all
of your pets brains so when you press
the one you actually deleted their
brains and now they just wander
aimlessly throughout your house eating
the wood floor and mumbling college
football fight song
they no longer accept love give love or
poop
they just pee a lot they spend more time
of the day teeing than not peeing so
your house has essentially become a
sewer oh my god Julian alright if you
continue to upload and just do what they
say yeah you find yourself ten years
later with nothing to show for the
subscribers you once earned on your
channel you are branded head to toe
literally with tattoos represented
representing Tom Cruise hit Tom Cruise's
new religion called play-doh dick jokes
the entire religion revolves around
making dick jokes about Plato the
philosopher all of your hardcore
subscribers came with you but since
Plato Dixit accept such a hypnotizing
religion they all think that they are
now Tom Cruise and they won't stop
tweeting you asking you to review
Mission Impossible 44 oh my god you like
that one yeah I'm pretty good say good
right so we have one more outcome it's
not the clown one you pick that one this
is okay you can come a Scientologists
start spreading the message but you're
doing it to expose them in your
documentary right okay a you end up
loving Scientology oh it's so fun you
bail on your original plan to be
undercover and you just become a
full-blown Scientologist and you get to
shock people into oblivion for just not
believing expensive garbage that your
scam call tries to push on people and
you live for it you hang out in the
sauna with Tom Cruise every day at night
[Laughter]
be years down the line you're on the
cusp of the biggest takedown of any
organized religion the world has ever
seen
right before you expose the Church of
Scientology you are uploading your video
you tube and you realize the whole time
you are filming anything inside the
church due to an invisible snapchat
geofilter on Scientology premises all of
your footage now just shows Gary Busey
facial expressions overlaid on top of
the original video and for audio do you
hear the mushy sounds that Guy Fieri
makes when he tells his hair with bacon
grease every morning
your film is now useless you don't know
how to turn see my god you wake up one
morning and you don't have you don't
have any memory over the past two years
you're naked and wet inside a blank room
you step on something sharp it's a giant
class ring and then another step you
step on another ring and then another
and another so all the floor has to walk
on is nothing but fat class rings that
have nothing to do with any school you
ever went to you realize you've seen
them before you don't know where they
look like something you used to watch on
TV and you start to remember something
then in the background you hear I want
you to get excited you're immediately
triggered you realize all those rings
that you're stepping on our doctor feels
random big rings that he wears on his
show of his fake doctor fingers you're
in fake doctor purgatory you have it
fully died yet but you are not in
afterlife yet either you have to get
yourself so excited about your life that
you can find like that and have peace
I'm guessing that one that's the one I
want
okay so then here's here's your life now
this existence I've drawn on you forty
five billion years have passed and you
have made decent friends with dr. Phil
by this time he's finally actually
gotten his ph.d and he stays up late
with you talking about boys and what's
got you down he's the BFF you wish you
had but instead you lost all your memory
and don't even know who you are
wait a minute dr. Phil isn't talking to
you dr. Phil is talking to himself
you are dr. Phil that's your life he
welcomed the camera look I wrote the
lessons um let me read you the other two
outcomes oh my god go for it so the
first one is if you end up loving
Scientology your outcome is your
Scientologist and you suck that's it
that's it Wow the second one is with the
Gary Busey not visage
I'm Jeff out there yeah you spend every
day for the rest of your life trying to
exact revenge on snapchat you try to
break into their offices steal their
confidential information from the
garbage outside their offices you said
you said mean and try to bully snapchat
on snapchat to snapchat account every
day then years passed and you soon
realize that snapchat the snapchat goes
is trying to tell you something he comes
into your apartment all the time and
talks to you in some foreign tongue but
you don't understand it it just sounds
like gibberish you go back to school and
major and everything 66 years later
you've achieved 66 degrees in college
and you're the single most decorated
college student to ever live snapchat
goes comes to a day and you get so
excited because you know that you can
finally understand it he leaves in your
ear pulls you closer and whispers never
gonna kidding for you oh my god Julian
I'm leaving all right well you're
getting rickroll me and it choose your
own adventures you got rickrolled if you
chose that one but you didn't so only
you guys got very probe's not Jenna how
did I do with that okay yeah it was
really good I liked it a lot it is very
creative I really particularly like the
bits of Ferrero Rocher and dr. Phil if
anything's gonna and Gary these
snapshots help I'm glad you liked it if
anything's gonna ever make really want
to really want as actual chocolate
factory come to life it's going to be
forever chair dog it's gone through and
I just like how you keep saying it
different every time you say it for
shame for a chair for a rotor for uber
overture you know writing that that
writing this there were times when I
actually felt like I was falling asleep
you know when you follow asleep while
you're watching TV you start to like
have what's happening on TV kind of
blend in to like a state that's how I
felt writing this I felt like I was
going a little nuts oh you were in a
trance I felt like I was in the trash
Julian is in a trance when he wrote that
genius about Ferrero Rocher I was in and
if someone tries to steal that idea
though we're going to know where you got
it we're going to know where it came
from it came from this brain the brain
of the man who has 66 college degrees so
I really said that that why hasn't
anyone ever done that like they're
driven everything
being a professional college student so
when you're done with college you go to
like another four-year college but then
you review colleges from the perspective
of a student like needle again always
critic but yes maybe you spend like one
year one semester at a school and then
that's your job you just go and you see
what it's like to be at that school and
then you write a comprehensive guide
book for all prospective students as to
what schools are awesome it's a very
good idea and I think good schools good
universities would welcome that bad
universities would be like no don't come
here I want you exposing I do want to
yes bully imaginet though would you
major in all all of that majored in
everything all of it that would suck
yeah your whole life is are studying for
tests
yeah no i yeah i'm going to formal I
mean not be lit you're like they're like
seventy or like Who am I going to go to
fun with I'm a science major alright
alright well I guess it's my turn to
play now so my that was really good
doing I really enjoyed that my structure
is a little bit different so the like
prompts the story prompt has a B and C
as choices and then from there
everything has an either/or so there's
only two loud yeah so it is a different
cool all right so here is the prompt
with three choices it turns out that
your phone has an inbuilt recording
device that has documented every phone
call you have ever made and what was
said it also isn't able to record
conversations you've had when it's been
in your pocket close to you so every
shitty thing you have ever said about
your friends colleagues family partner
is on file hackers have gotten this
information and are planning on leaking
this to the people you have slammed do
you a smash the phone hope to hell that
works then flee the USA and set up a
life in another country off the grid you
will never let anyone know of your
whereabouts and will live out of the
rest of your days chopping firewood and
hand making weapons and pooping in the
forest or will you be right sorry notes
everyone you know for all the things
that they are about to find out throw
throw an I'm an [ __ ] party and ply
them with alcohol in hopes they forgive
you you will also present each of them a
check for $1,000 for damages plus offer
psychiatric help to those who need it or
see contact a scientist to come up with
a mind erasing drug that you will
administer to all your phone contacts so
they'll never remember all the shitty
things you've said about them then
ensure you will never use a mobile phone
again and rely only on sending letters
to all correspondence you know just
purely logistically I don't think C is
possible because how are they just going
to forget the things that you want them
to forget to remember everything else
like whatever they are that you're your
friend so I'm going go you know I've
always I've always fantasized about
going off the grid chopping wood and
pooping in the forest so I'm going to go
with pay alright grid here we go
remember to 0l movement I didn't want to
get Camille Hudson made this comment
suggestion on one of our podcasts no no
yeah committal thank you for this all
right here you go Julia yeah you find
yourself beef in the woods of New
Zealand you're barefoot you're tired
you're almost out of fried rice you pack
for yourself for your flight because
you've only just arrived like an hour
ago
hi you say to yourselves you rip the
bottom of your pant leg off to make a
tourniquet for the paper cut you got on
your finger from your plane ticket you
plop down on the ground start wrapping
your tourniquet around your shoulder for
some reason I guess that paper cut is
really [ __ ] brutal and you look up to
the beautiful sunshiny sky and yell why
God why have you stranded me here
so you've isolated yourself but you know
you've been there for an hour it's
getting rough when suddenly you hear a
rustling to your left
what the [ __ ] is that you audibly yell
do you eh
go investigate the noise or be start
running to your right can make a couple
comments real quick yeah okay first of
all the fried rice bit very accurate I
feel like I'm already in this story and
paper cut I definitely cut my finger on
my plane ticket because I got my finger
on everything you need a tourniquet
around your shoulder for that because
it's getting bad out there
that I'd like to think I would run
towards it to investigate but I'm a big
old [ __ ] I would probably run away
you're gonna run away yeah let's go with
run away yeah okay oh man
you make off like the wind but like
really noisy crunchy wind but all of
those years of playing video games have
finally paid off as your cardio at this
point is nothing short of exceptional
your fingers are pointed at the sky as
you pump your arms almost completely up
and down which isn't even helping you go
faster in fact you really just look like
a complete [ __ ] crunch crunch crunch
go your feet you look down and see that
you've accumulated some debris in your
toes sticks twigs a McDonald's cup ooh I
wonder if there's anything in there I'm
starving you one leg run for a minute
and check the cup other arms still
pumping straight up at the sky rats just
as I thought the cup was literally felt
as rats McDonald's sometimes totally has
rats in their food and you know you know
that thanks to the internet you reach a
small river and without even thinking
you just run straight into it waist-deep
and then you you and then you begin to
move there's a current it's only a waist
high current you're not in danger but
still what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] you
start moving down the river when a
rowboat knocks you square in the head
WTF mate you scream because you've been
in this hemisphere for like an hour so
you've already picked up an accent do
you flip the boat over or look to see
who's in the boat to flip the boat over
eyes and like tip them off yeah cuz
you're mad just hit you in the head
doesn't a faint or would you like to
look and see them both I would look to
see who's in the boat
ok tight you see
can you take it there's a lot of writing
all right you're looking at seas in the
boat yes okay who the [ __ ] is in that
boat mate why are you driving like that
mate you look up and see gasp ah the
ghost of Steve Irwin here to film his
hit ghost show the crocodile watcher
from heaven wow you are so blessed to
finally catch a live taping you shake
his air hand I mean your hand really
just passes through an apparition but
still then it was cool and he said sorry
for hitting with my boat mate would you
like to be on the crocodile watch her
from heaven and you say hell yeah and
she says oh no no no so you can't say
help on air you understand crocodile
watch her from heaven sorry you say
really loud you hop up into his boat and
turn on your camera face and you are the
newest reality-tv Tsar in all of heaven
they love the episode then they sign you
to have an Illuminati and you got
sacrifice but whatevs it was worth it
the end so you guys went to heaven
you're a star not bad yeah but then you
joined heaven Illuminati right that's a
cover what a ride it's been
you know what arrived if you're going to
go to the afterlife I'd say that's the
way to do it I'm happy with my choices
mm-hmm what would have happened if we
flipped the boat okay you flick that
[ __ ] over nobody hits me in my
own head nobody you scream loudly
underwater because when you flip the
blow it flipped on top of you and now
you're underwater the waters only waist
but you have a severe fear of capsized
boats you forgot about and your whole
head is just in there man it's not
looking good you struggle and struggle
but this toon rowboat man used for
prepared for this kind of survival you
start to see a light you're choking
water and you die but it's okay because
little did you know
King John moon actually super hates New
Zealand and nuked it the next day so you
leash you up some wow wow I'm so glad I
died the other way was Steve Irwin
because that's horrible denna
the first thing I thought of when you
said in the woods of New Zealand was
primitive technology I was like oh I'm
just going to imagine that that's me now
funny you should say that would you like
to see I would are no internet let's
hear the alternative try so this is when
you're in the woods like right when you
find yourself there okay if you had
chose to go investigate the noise yes
yes you started quietly but not really
because of your giant man body make your
way through the sick brush your feet
keep some how loudly crunching every
branch anywhere in a 20-foot vicinity of
yourself really though how is this
happening it is so [ __ ] loud your
hands covered in mud because you got
hella dirty from being outdoors for one
haul our superfast you pull aside a
large leafy branch and look into a small
clearing is that no it can't be
you loudly crunch your way closer to see
oh my god it is it's none other than the
one and only YouTube superstar primitive
technology hanging out with homemade
clay huts he looks up from his clay kiln
in the ground he made entirely out of
elements around him and says Oi
[ __ ] off out of here do you beg him to
talk to you for just a second so you can
explain your situation or [ __ ] off out
of here I'd beg him okay let me get
there this was like seven pages long
yeah you wrote like very descriptive
prose alright so you chose to talk to
you primitive technology might dude I'm
a big fan I stuck to on YouTube I love
you dude you say to him as you kneel
next to him trying to honestly smell him
a little get his scent you huffing a
deep breath of air listen you say I've
had to go off the grid because of a
series of unfortunate events and I'm out
here now like I know you're out here but
like I'm really out here man let me live
in one of your huts and like teach me
how to take care of myself please man I
have a little fried rice to repay you
with or like anything you want anything
I want boy he keeps saying always but
nobody knows why oi you say anything you
want
alright boy I
on I want you bring that [ __ ] he
moans and leans in and wrestles you to
the ground you giggle infectiously you
start making out primitive technology
pickles you in whispers it's been so
long since I've found someone I truly
wanted to spend the rest of my life with
Oy and I smelled you just now and I got
your scent
oi and we're just meant to be together I
just know it boy
boy you say back as you caress his hair
and you lived in the woods happily ever
after the end
boy boy I like that one well done I feel
like if I went up to him and said I'm
your biggest fan please let me live in
your Hut he'd be like fake fan if you
were my biggest fan you'd know how to
make your own huh that's shit's good
okay so what other choices have a mess
let's go to the other ones
well do you want to know if you didn't
talk to him and you wanted to [ __ ] up
out of here that one yo-yo
okay you start [ __ ] off out of here
you keep walking all the way off until
nightfall oh no you think where will I
sleep well you just keep bond [ __ ]
off [ __ ] off as far as you can until you
die you become the first person in the
history of ever to die from a couple of
hours of starvation and [ __ ] off the
good news me this is good news is though
the scientists use your body to make
great leaps and bounds with people with
celiac disease and [ __ ] off now and
everyone can eat weed again except for
you because you're dead from starving
and [ __ ] off you know what I think a
bullet for the rest of the field yard
shout-out to Julien the celiac Lord and
Savior that's what I want to be known as
and instead of amen they would just say
[ __ ] off [ __ ] off out of here [ __ ] off
out of here is something we heard gordon
ramsay gordon ramsay say like a hundred
times on one of his shows and we
implement it in everyday language pretty
much three much all right I think that's
all for that starry line so we have
another's we have one or two of the
other choices the in response to your
phone has been hacked and everything so
let's do the memory erasing one more
whenever I send my hire scientists to
erase my memories so just to recap in
case you've gotten so far lost your
phone has been hacked and every
conversation you've ever had on or near
your phone has been recorded and hackers
are going to release it so this choice
is you contact scientists to come up
with mind-erasing drugs that you'll
administer it all your phone contacts
will never remember anything okay here
we go
you pull slowly up to the driveway and
put the car in park it's just another
Tuesday and you're here to pick up your
mom for lunch like always you make your
way up the front steps when your mom's
two dogs puppy and honey begin violently
barking at you dude like violent puppy
grabs ahold of your ankle while honey
somehow flies all the way up to your
neck and grabs you by your jugular holy
[ __ ] you think to yourself I talk [ __ ]
about puppy and honey - hon they don't
know who I am you start screaming it's
Julianne it's me but the dogs tiny
little mouth somehow clenched even
tighter your mom makes it to the door to
see what the commotion is you've you're
relieved until you see her here so
you're like finally someone can help me
she looks at you and screams intruder
get the [ __ ] off my property I'm going
to call the police do you follow her
into the house there has to be a way to
make her remember who you are or do you
make your way to your car we have some
dog treats to try to lure the dogs off
you go into the house okay EB go peepee
hold up mom you scream mom it's me
Julianne your [ __ ] stars holy [ __ ]
that drug was serious like you seriously
don't even remember me at all I only
have one son and he has red hair and it
would be good hacker and be single
ladies hit them up because someday
Jenna's going to need a dope-ass
sister-in-law like know what I'm saying
like someone get drinks lids like maybe
babysit her kids and like hang out with
the family events like for real modeling
don't [ __ ] this up man we need a cool
felony number dog you staring her half
blankly and half like you're getting
your throat ripped out by a small orange
dog that likes to piddle when she's
excited why the [ __ ] did you say that
mom like how come you remember Jenna you
don't remember me your son do
because Jared's [ __ ] awesome
everybody knows that she says oh you say
tight tight she says back now get the
[ __ ] out I'm calling the police mom no
you scream out of desperation I can
prove I'm your son prove it she says do
you put on your roller skates and Ninja
Turtle outfit from when you were a kid
and show her if that's what used to look
like every single day or sing her a song
only her son would know
well I'd [ __ ] I wouldn't sing her a song
I would definitely call my roller skates
okay here we go I gotta get down and
hold on you put on your roller skates
and Ninja Turtle outfit that you used to
wear every day they're kind of small for
your man body but like you're working it
honestly it looks good tight
everything's tight two feet hover audio
roller skates for like you're athletic
enough to pull it off see mom it's me
you exclaim you start crying like a
little baby at the thought of your own
mother forgetting who you are but also
because the Ninja Turtle outfit is like
totally cutting your sack in half she
locks eyes with you tears start to well
up she opens her mouth and says I knew
it was you haha lol I started to prank
youtube channel alright fam make sure
you smash that like button subscribe to
set to the camera over look they're over
here - she says she pours out like four
different cameras how the [ __ ] did you
see those haha stupid and then your mom
became the most beloved prank channel on
YouTube the end I ate an outcome
why did you remember Jenna because she's
awesome done what would happen if I if I
left right for no I don't know if I
saying yeah that's one or instead of
going inside the house you could go get
a dog treat yeah what happened if I got
the dog treat okay hold on let me find
it Wow give me a second
okay you make your way to your car you
reach for your glove box there's always
dog treats in there
aha you found one a greenie it's old and
hard but hopefully it'll do the trick
you whip it up to your neck to give it
to honey she instantly drops to the
ground puppy let's go to they both
peddle a little because they're excited
and stupid like how dogs are you break
it in half and give one to each puppy
sits down like a little lady and starts
to in hers with her hands while honey
somehow doesn't even eat hers it's just
gone it's like she just absorbed it with
a guy then honey looks up to you and
says sup Julian you gasp and cluster
Ches you guess and clutch your chest
because you've been watching so much
RuPaul's Drag Race all of your
expressions have subconsciously been
affected to become extra you don't know
which one to be more shocked at the fact
that your dog just talked or the fact
that this animal just tried to kill you
because they forgot who you were but
then remembered who you were you you
remember me honey
oh good girl honey what a good girl
honey rose over onto her back and
pedaled straight up into the air while
maintaining eye contact with you yeah
sorry she says and so does your mom
she's just honestly been watching a lot
of RuPaul's Drag Race that if
subconsciously become extra so she's
like half pretending she doesn't know
who you are like the drug erase her
brain because I honestly think she just
want some attention
toughy continues to meticulously nibble
her grainy she's eating it in a straight
line from left to right like a book what
the [ __ ] do you go inside and give the
frightened your mom or keep talking to
honey I keep talking about okay I like
this conversation
hold on sorry you keep talking to honey
honey how can you talk you ask oh
because that drug you gave everyone yeah
I got into it I totally thought it was a
tiny little bit of like a fresh roasted
chicken at least I thought that's not
like what I imagined while I was eating
it and then I imagined it was a
hamburger when I threw it up but then
because you so irresponsibly made and
administered a drug that wasn't
regulated by the FDA whatsoever one of
the side effects for dogs is like
immense growth and speech so now I can
talk she rolls back up to her feet and
somehow piddles straight directly into
your pant legs what the [ __ ] you say
your mom comes out of the house and
yells Julie it's me I'm just kidding
mommy's here Oh what happened to your
neck and you're like dude the dogs Benny
I don't know and she's like Joanna
scammer is my favorite I'm trying to
live my life like that so honey looks
iron says honestly truly and then tees
and six concentric circles because it's
the end you and the honey peddling I
like that one moans good while
maintaining eye contact okay so if I go
inside and to confront my mom here
there's so much more in depth because
it's like a like a story
all right go inside and confront your
mom see da it's like really hard and I
was hard to write like organization wise
mm-hmm okay you storm into the house to
confront your mom mom you yell you
remember me don't you
you're just being [ __ ] extra honey
told me she flips her hair exquisitely
and says oh my lord no tea no shade no
tea lemonade but yes Julie I'm sorry I
just want you to come home or I miss you
mom don't do that with milk mom you guys
just said that I'm your son I love you
and she says I love you too so more oka
are these our opossums yet so that was
that was
tell me no tea no shade no tea lemon oh
my god help me okay do you wanna know
what would happen if you sang your song
a song to your mom instead of putting on
relish or yeah yeah yeah okay so if when
you went inside you didn't go outside
you can get dog treats you went inside
you can find your mom and instead of
putting on your roller skates and you
Ninja Turtle cuffs and you sing her a
song only her son would know this is
that you rack your brain what's a song
to prove my mom it's me pink Julian sink
then a light bulb goes off you got it
you take a deep breath taking the light
three times cover your eyes and sing
mochila hemming ha rats we give thanks
to God for bread our voices rising in
song together as our joyful parish said
barakat ion I Elohim Ellen olam moti let
her me Haresh ah you look up to see your
mom she starts dying laughing mom why
are you laughing you just sang the
Jewish song for eating bread dog like
everyone knows that stuff if you do that
I can't
idiot get the [ __ ] out so you leave your
mom's house and she totally did actually
forget who you were and it's all because
you sang her homotopy like lol even I
know that song oh the end oh my to be
fair I never actually knew that song
what I knew the Hanukkah song what
that's different
similar did you not know that song
because we sang the Hanukkah song mm
okay
like on ilt milk on share case honey but
it's beside the divan it will hardly
know she'll buy new car
okay we have one more outcome right yeah
the first one where you throw the party
and apologize and give them money and
yes all of your friends all this
information is leaked that you're
talking [ __ ] about them so you right
sorry notes and then you throw a party
like cost a lot of money yeah and well
how much [ __ ] you talk I guess are you
ready I am her this environment
it's the evening of your big party
everyone's invited and excited to
finally get to face you in person you're
fixing all of your I'm sorry banners
around the exquisite chuck-e-cheese you
chose as a venue you figured it would
help lighten the doom and gloom plus
everyone's allowed to order only one
drink at a time only one beer at a time
and have one beer in their hand at a
time
you ever been to HIV cheese's that's how
it works actually heaven also though
because there will be [ __ ] kids there
also side bar you didn't tell the this
locations manager Karen that this was
the purpose of your party poor Karen but
she also like really clearly doesn't
give a [ __ ] what happens there and seems
to be on some kind of methamphetamine
guests are arriving before you know it
the whole room is full of everyone you
know and their friends for moral support
and without even a moment to welcome
them the verbal abuse begins you're in
the center of a swirling attack from all
directions not knowing which bit role to
listen to first you fixate your eyes at
the animatronic chuck-e-cheese you gaze
into his cold dead creepy gross ass
dusty as crusty ass expression you're
prepared for hours of this when suddenly
both double doors to the front burst
open
a gust of wind hits you in your face and
blow those adorable glasses back under
your forehead do you hey look up to see
who it is or keep staring it's Satan
cheese it doesn't matter who it is but
I'm going to suck no matter what I need
to know this is you knocked my glasses
off my face
can you say Satan cheese crappy-ass got
yes you pull your eyes away from Satan
cheese somehow his gaze is super demonic
sits like it did take a second that
thing is like a portal or something and
look at the door to see none other than
Guy Fieri himself he stomps his thick
thighs in Asia he starts the stick size
and age-inappropriate heavy black
creepers over to you he pushes 60-year
friends and also a group of small
children into the skee-ball machine in
one fell swoop with his giant throbbing
webbed hands which are also still
covered in wing sauce from his
appearance on hot ones the kids start
crying confused as to how they literally
just got attacked by a grown man and a
Chucky Cheese he turns around and says
few kids don't shut the [ __ ] up I'm
gonna [ __ ] your but innocent parents
unaware of the verbal abuse party start
frantically gathering their children
begin begin dialing 911 call that [ __ ]
about me huh hombre hombre he says
hombre because he thinks it's cool but
like with a distinctly American accent
which makes him like sound kind of
racist to be age you scoff because like
it's 2017 come on dude he squeezes your
wiener and leans in close to close his
mouth is now on your mouth he says into
your mouth but I heard what you and that
little rat-faced Jenna had been saying
about me on your podcast and I just want
you to know his lips are touching your
lips I'm here I just want you to know
that it's not cool man keep tongue
kisses you really hard and it's spicy
too holy for you
hey keep kissing him back [ __ ] it or be
push him off you I keep kissing it back
okay let me get there
okay your mouth is literally inside Guy
Fieri's mouth but somehow you're kissing
your tongue begins to go numb from the
300,000 Scoville level of hotness that
he has left in there from eating chicken
wings you say into Guy Fieri's mouth I'm
sorry for what I said about you man it
was just a joke he twists your wiener
directly up which is super hard right
now by the way because how could you not
and he says into your mouth but it's
okay dude I forgive you but like respect
me I do you say hey let's go your mouth
with his mouth and lets your boner just
hang around there because Sakhalin is
done squeezing it then he slaps you on
the butt winks at you and turns around
to leave the cops tackle him to the
ground for assaulting minor so he looks
up at you you down at him and he yells
out when I get out of jail I'm still
gonna [ __ ] your butt to the kids which
is like so horrible but you think to
yourself he'll always be the one that
got away he will be it Oh God
do you want to know if you push them off
yeah okay you push guy fieri off off you
which is no easy feat like it literally
took all of your energy holy [ __ ] that
is a big man look I'm sorry guy you
exclaimed it's just a joke dude relax
and stop [ __ ] kissing me man I've
only had one beer today I'm not drunk
enough for that [ __ ] Karen the mess
manager comes over and tries to break up
the situation and she's not even making
English words at this point plus she's
speaking directly into your forehead
which is super not helpful and like
downright distracting when all of a
sudden you hear this awful noise what
the [ __ ] was that guy looks at you
concerned he holds his own button says
damn I took myself again everyone starts
laughing and suddenly no one maddy you
anymore because guy fieri just moved his
pants he walks out with his poop pants
and says everyone else oh that the end
right ending I love
I mean the cat had pooped himself again
for the last choice is if I stare at
Chuck E Cheese instead of a look at the
door
yeah you see okay yeah so if you be if
you don't look up to see ya stir yeah
okay it doesn't matter who's at the door
nothing matters honestly [ __ ] it all he
stared deep into chuck-e-cheeses eyes
wow it's like way totally dead in here
you think the walls around you become
fuzzy everything is getting distorted
you can't even really hear what anyone
is saying anymore which is like kind of
a good thing because a bunch of [ __ ] you
you little jujitsu [ __ ] just came out
which really does hurt your feeling
because you just is a great sport and
should be left out of this you keep
gazing it's almost as if you're moving
closer to him
you keep gazing oh my god wait you know
what you are actually moving closer to
him this eyes are a demonic portal and
you're getting sucked oh oh my god we're
in hell I'm in Hell right now would you
look at that Jackie chooses eyes are in
actual demonic portal I can't wait to
post this on snapchat do you pull out
your phone to try to take a snapchat or
B start checking the place out
definitely snapchat okay you go B P
you pull out your phone to take a
snapchat surprisingly there's like such
good service down here because it's
where the owner of Comcast a AOL and
Time Warner little it's like lightning
fast down here like damn life hack you
have it first pacing you invent yeah you
have you first have it facing you okay
guys so finally sorry I'm in Hell right
now with the but oh you double tap and
flip the screen around and show the
fiery lava pits and souls being tortured
post you go to your Twitter scroll
through your mentions what what the hell
pun intended
fake fake this is fake Julian you're
[ __ ] stupid well melon was
unnecessary fake everyone think this is
fake
damn it then you never actually figured
out a way out of there which is why you
really so many people go missing from
chuck-e-cheeses and everyone thinks your
snapchat is fake the end okay hey why
aren't there geofilters in hell and B if
everyone thought I was fake I would have
just scrolled over to the temperature
snapchat filter and it would be my five
hundred thousand degrees Fahrenheit I
was good though okay so if I go looking
the place up yeah you start walking
around hell but you can't help but say
to yourself when in hell lol you come up
those weird little opening a fire when
you see a man relaxing in an easy-chair
reading a book by flaming eternal hell
light how is that you leaned in closer
and see oh oh it's Adolf Hitler you get
scared but then you're like when in hell
lol and then you're like hey man [ __ ]
you but then you forget he speaks German
so he actually just pulls his fire blind
shot and it like totally catches you on
fire and then you burn there and but
it's fast and painless so what if so I
got I got burned by Hitler and hell yeah
I'm glad I made out with KY Fieri then
hmm never thought I'd say that sense hmm
actually I did who are we kidding
Tony I Bravo I mean your writing is just
I felt like I was there the whole time I
mean I feel like I was just making jokes
but that's off that was just that was
did yes son I was fine I like that now I
know I got to step my [ __ ] up for the
next time I also know that like I want
to I want to do the case or this so I
can either or I like that because it
keeps the storyline more linear yeah
yeah space fun that was fun
that's fun hopefully you guys enjoyed us
playing choose your address if you want
us to play it again maybe give us some
ideas of different themes we can use or
or you know even if you have adventures
you'd like us to play let us know but I
definitely enjoyed this as Lima this is
like a lot of page at one two three four
yeah I have I think I had four and a
half year seven eight
yes I mean fun we need double spacing
dude wait we're going Ricky move double
spacing your essay to get our pages that
really are learned that they have a
default elbow stays it's a day I
remember em to college in high school
and had to get more pages on the essay
boy wait a minute wait a minute what
size font is that that's cuz I copied
and pasted of that what's wrong with you
eighteen point font
yeah that part the rest of the twelve
exposed oh my god
so I saw my mother writing you [ __ ]
choose yours but no don't get mad you
were just rubbing in my face but I only
had four pages in you at 34 our Russian
God ever will be I'm starting or I'm
running a Kickstarter to fund for tear
factories you can make four arrow chairs
Alex we can't eat that dude it's [ __ ]
it's milk chocolate um you don't piss
where you eat this is my business
okay I'm not eating it I'm using it to
make money nasty ferrero chair also that
is the single most delicate candy in the
world or dessert in the world how could
you shoot that I have a paintball gun
you can't you can you can actually help
oh good job good job does fun that was
fun in all actuality she wrote a [ __ ]
ton you guys know that but yeah will be
again and I'll see you guys next middle
part guys thanks so much
[Music]
[Music]